have you guys ever experienced what
thirst is not having to drink a single
drop of water for days these people have
our fridges are full of water please
give whatever you can for the sake of
allah so they can have something to
drink
i used to struggle reading the quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app i never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatu brothers and
sisters and dear friends this video was
sent to me like eight months ago nine
months ago and these things repeatedly
come when i see someone repeatedly
coming over and over again i get
concerned about it so someone contacted
me and said that their cousin is
actually thinking of going to this
person because she's deaf if i'm not
mistaken and i spoke to a cousin and i
might even interview her we're going to
see inshallah i'm just trying to find
out what's exactly happening but let's
watch this video now in this video this
is an individual who's claiming
to
heal people let's watch some of these
clips and understand what an earth is
really going on who is this person and
is this action from the quran
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
as you saw for yourself that now
some weird stuff is happening like he's
putting his finger down people's throat
uh he's doing stuff like
like you know it's like playing you know
young girls used to pray uh play yeah
okay um
i saw a video of a brother called
abnordir if i'm mistaken that's his name
i couldn't i tried to get in contact
with him maybe he was busy he didn't
reply i recommend i'm gonna put his
video in the bottom please check that
video because this he breaks it down
properly i want you to follow him
because he does a good job i'm done i
can't deal with everything i'll just i
can highlight the issue now from what i
know there is nothing in the quran or
the sunnah
that tells you you can heal someone by
putting your hand in the throat or etc
yes the quran is a shifa yes indeed it's
the sri lanka allah says in the quran
and we believe it to be a shifa but the
thing is here like one thing you notice
with this individual that he when he
does these things he says you know it's
not it's not me it's allah
understandable respectable humble seems
like it but the thing is yeah we need to
ask a big question mark because the
thing is now
if if it's not if if it's not you like
you know that's the brotherhood that
said um if it's not you
and it is allah that's doing it then
what's special about you
i don't know which why can't i do it and
i'm gonna do it without touching i'm
just gonna read the quran because the
thing is here you're putting a question
mark in people's minds because the thing
is people are sadly weak sheep mind it
and they flock flock to people like this
okay and this is where allah tests the
believers like he said do not say that
you're going to believe and not be
tested you are going to be tested
because to see if you truly believe why
is it that we go like this we have this
attitude that we think that the cure is
in the individual yes we might think oh
it's from allah but we think the person
has some kind of supernatural powers
shifa comes from allah
it is allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and if
allah hasn't cured be patient
you have to be patient you can't if you
cross boundaries then we have an issue
of tahit because now you're saying okay
i can't be patient i want to look for
help well i always immediately with that
people the people that you go to these
um people who go and you pay and say
yeah go and do this work with jinns god
knows what else they're gonna do they're
gonna make your life worse have tawakkul
in allah subhanahu wa ta'ala be patient
don't go to these people i'm being
honest i would personally warn you
against this person i have to because
he's doing some weird stuff and you can
catch him you can catch me and you can
easily see i'm gonna click um put a
video at the end of charlotte you can
see for yourself
and you can see how this brother breaks
this down how that this doesn't seem
right yes as far as if he's not asking
money if he's praising allah and saying
you know this is from allah not me i
understand about that doesn't give it a
legitimacy it doesn't say oh just
because he's doing this and praising
allah and saying it's got enough to do
with me okay good but the point is again
you're doing things that are not
according to the quran and the sunnah
yeah certain actions etc
um
and the thing is that why is it that you
can do it that i can't do it why can't i
go and do it et cetera and if that's the
case if you can cure these people yeah
we've got a long list of a lot of people
who are ill my friend can you come to
wherever you are and start curing people
in the hospitals please yeah
this is not from the religion people
think religion means that we religious
people think that you know when it comes
yes we believe god almighty has we
believe in miracles we believe allah can
cure if somebody is deaf blind whatever
it may be allah can cure if you win if
he wills yeah these modern signs come in
this these are all things allah has
given these are the things that allah
has given that you're working with to
cure things people yeah and then what do
you do give the credit to the scientists
oh he did an amazing job what about the
one who gave him the brain what about
the one who gave him all the tools to
make this thing yeah you're working with
god almighty's creation and you're
picking yourself up for that my friend
you can't do nothing on your own you're
using with materials that god almighty's
created already so brothers and sisters
the reason i'm doing this is be wary
about this individual do not go to him
or anyone for that matter last two years
ago we had someone
what the what the hell is this
and we've got crowd of people holding
their heads like this something like
that sorry it looks like i'm dancing
yeah they're holding their heads like
this or something like that and you've
got someone
what is this choo-choo train thomas the
tank engine what the hell is this yeah
it's a joke it's becoming a joke and you
know what the more you guys do this the
more you're humiliating yourself imagine
a
whole
audience or people man in birmingham or
breath wherever it was in a line holding
their heads and one guy doing choo-choo
like a train track like you're waiting
for a train station uh
stop brothers and sisters have two in
allah do not do not put your trust be
married you can't get married whatever
it is
put your trust in allah allah will aid
you that's all i have to say inshallah
and check that video i'm going to put at
the end and watch this video breaks it
down and these actions be wary be wary
we don't know who he is i don't want to
say anything but what i'm saying is be
warned about it inshallah that's my job
with this platform to inform you guys
about things people have a question mark
that's all i have to say till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh